romrod mit globetrotter dann spezialist
für niedrige reiter rath globetrotter
punktzahl
[Musik]
jetzt willkommen gelandet und was mir an
china immer wieder fasziniert
zwischenahn sich alles verändert der
neue flughafen dänischen kurz beispiele
für das ist mittlerweile der viertgrößte
in china um 2,8 millionen gestiegen und
umstiegen
[Musik]
kunming ist die hauptstadt der
südwestlichen provinz yunnan eine stadt
im aufschwung
wird der verkehr immer mehr zum problem
ja es gibt oft massiven stau
besonders in der rush hour was ist der
grund es gibt immer mehr privater
personenwagen
allein in kunming werden fünf millionen
autos im jahr verkauft bin ich etwa
einen monat pro jahr in staub staube
peter ströhle stadtrat und einen kombi
entschieden sich immer mehr ohne
betreuung vermeiden rad und zurück
vom input die rasante entwicklung wurde
durch ein gigantisches
konjunkturprogramm der zentralregierung
in peking angeschoben
heute kurbelt vor allem die junge mit
geschichte der konsum künftig an
zur schweiz gibt es eine ganz besondere
verbindung
vor 33 jahren wurde die
städtepartnerschaft mit zürich
geschlossen
damals 1982 waren beide städte
ähnlich groß heute leben in kunming so
viele menschen wie in der ganzen schweiz
dass die altstadt so aussieht ist auch
ziemlich zu verdanken gebäude während
restauriert
das ist rar in china wo man altes
aufzureißen trägt und im alten stil neu
aufbaut
ich treffe den bee gees koonings design
direktorin und leitet die
renovationsarbeiten sie zeigt mir unter
maus schreckensherrschaft in den 70er
jahren alles was nach bush war sie roch
zerstört wurde
ich möchte ihnen ein wichtiges stück
geschichte zeigen wieso wurde diese
darstellung entfernt
das geschah während der kulturrevolution
die dargestellten menschen trugen sehr
vornehme kleider
man befürchtete einen schlechten
einfluss auf das proletariat also
entfernten sie diese bilder das
restauration steam fragte mich ob sie
den original zustand wiederherstellen
sollen
ich entschied mich dagegen als mahnmal
damit sich die geschichte im juni
wiederholt
[Musik]
das bewusstsein für die vergangenheit
ist gewachsen
ein wenig auch dank ziemlich
von der vergangenheit in die zukunft wir
sind geht's und wachsen oft schenkung
statt 25 km außerhalb vom stadtzentrum
zum komischen ziel gebaut wurde und der
stadt wien bereits virtualisiert
schönbohm wurde 2003 vor zwölf jahren
aus dem nichts erwartet es soll koonings
handels und verwaltungszentrum werden
und alle universitäten der provinz hunan
wurden hierher versetzt
hier sollen bald 250.000 studentinnen
und studenten ein und ausgehen dass sie
die sollten mal 1,5 millionen menschen
und schaffe ich habe mich wieder einige
riesen über bbc
und viele davon sind regelrechte geister
steht kann sich in not baut wurde das
ist achtmal dürfen ist die für geld
sondern ums wachstumskurve noch darüber
oder finanzkrise hat regiert aber sie
geben ganz so lars bauer us
bruttoinlandprodukt internet treiben und
herausforderung ist jetzt die kreis
versteht und die rieser bewerber mit
mannschaftsführer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier in hongkong will mehr eine wohnung
kaufen für seinen sohn da serie dessen
chancen auf dem heiratsmarkt ist der
vater überzeugt
mein sohn ist 33 jahre alt und
unverheiratet
er ist spät dran und ich mache mir große
sorgen wenn ich für ihn eine wohnung
kaufen hat er etwas eigenes in china
herrscht wälder überschuss eine folge
der ein-kind-politik weibliche föten
werden oft abgetrieben
da es mehr männer gibt haben frauen die
wahl und einmal mit modem und autor hat
bessere chancen auf eine frau in dieser
immobilienagentur sind mittelstands
paare die hauptkundschaft für viele ist
eine wurden auch als anlageobjekt
attraktiv sie möchten eine
wohnungsbesichtigung ja sind sie zum
ersten mal hier
ja kommen sie bitte mit sie sind herr
ich heiße may willkommen herr ich heiße
show ja das ist in zwei zonen aufgeteilt
es gibt ein geschäftsviertel und ein
wohnviertel
unsere größte wohnung ist 176
quadratmeter die kleinste 57 wie groß
soll ihre wohnung seien um 90
quadratmeter eine 90 quadratmeter große
dreizimmerwohnung genau 100 sind auch
okay
die gigantische überbauung zählt 6700
wohnungen die meisten stehen aber noch
leere geschäfte gibt es nur wenige die
investoren halten sich bisher zurück
im frühling 2016 soll die ganze
überbauung bezugsbereit sein
diese wanderarbeiter schaffen dafür
häufig sieben tage die woche
allein hier sollen 2.000 menschen wollen
willkommen
bitte ziehen sie das über bitte nehmen
sie platz
das ist unsere modell
sie misst 103 sie kommen direkt ins
geräumige wohnzimmer
hier haben wir den essbereich und hier
ist die küche sie ist offen das ist
momentan sehr angesagt gleich im
anschluss fahren wir den balkon
das ist das zweite zimmer
es wurde vom thema prinzessin inspiriert
die fläche ist relativ groß ungefähr elf
quadratmeter mit balkon sind es 13
das zimmer ist nach süden ausgerichtet
und hat gutes tages im
elternschlafzimmer können sie vielleicht
einen schrank einbauen die wohnung
kostet 650.000 die 100000 franken
das ist etwa das zehnfache eines
jahreslohns in kunming wäre sie doppelt
so teuer
es ist eine finanzielle belastung ich
hoffe dass sich die wohnung bis in 20
jahren zurückzahlen kann
abends wird in kunming küchen gekocht
gedämpft und flambiert was das zeug hält
zweimal am tag sollst du dich glücklich
essen lautet ein chinesisches gebot hier
in lünern sei das pflichtzeit mir der
chefkoch die chinesischen gerichte
müssen um aus dem duft und im geschmack
her perfekt sein
alle chinesen lieben es zu essen essen
muss einfach alles stimmen
das restaurant ist bekannt für seine
fischgerichte mal schauen wie viel chili
mein team verträgt die kirche hinaus
gehört zu meinen lieblings küchen in
china
denn sie ist berühmt für ihre scharfen
speisen nichts für weichlinge
sensationelles und süchtig nach chili
von der israelitischen nach seiner
obsession genauso wie sauber es gibt
sogar chinesische berufswahl somit im
ausland und habe sehr viel mit der
ersten chance
[Musik]
im green lake in konin wird sie morgens
gymnastik gemacht
ein relikt der 50er jahre als präsident
macedo dem volk bewegung verordnete
heute bewegen sich die chinesen
freiwillig und sorgen so für ihre
gesundheit
es sind vor allem pensionen die sport
betreiben
[Musik]
ich war dreizehn schon immer fasziniert
heute erhalte ich meine ersten privat
stunde
[Musik]
o
es ist also viel schwieriger so sich
unglaublich beute wieder ab um sie
reichen von der perfekten tut mir ja gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich versuche biegsam wie ein baum musste
sein so wie meine lehrerin das von mir
verlangt
die fülle von 60 jährige übt jeden tag
seit 30 jahren
kg wurde von unseren vorfahren
überliefert und hat eine 5000 jahre die
maschine der chinesen lieben bis weil es
unseren körper trainiert und unser
bewusstsein erreicht dabei eine höhere
ebene so kann sich eine 50-jährige 20
jahre jünger fühlen das ist der sinn
würde mich regelmäßiges training ruhiger
machen ja macht gestresste menschen müde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in kooning beginnt die legendäre und
burma roth
er arbeitete früher für mit seiner frau
thea heute zeit der touristen die
oldtimer roth dieses monument erinnert
an deren bau 19 37
da oben sieht man die erbauer der roma
und sie benutzten walzen um die straße
zu reden
der belag war aus kieselsteinen der
junge da war in wahrheit ein mädchen das
die steine zerkleinerte der großteil der
straße wurde von frauen gebaut aber
dieses denkmal zeigt nur männer
ja es gab aus heroischer akt daran
wurden romana dargestellt
harry ist unser fahrer wir sind nun auf
der sagenumwobenen und burma roth sie
hat eine länge von rund 1200 kilometer
ausgangspunkt unserer reise ist südchina
von kunming aus folgende der oldtimer
rot bis an die grenze zu myanmar geht
mir hier maligen burma entlang leeren
straßen erreichen wir die einstige
hauptstadt yangon der handelswege führen
uns von nordindien über die themen
politik schilling reise beenden wir in
kalkutta dem heutigen co katar die zahl
der autos nimmt ab dass hufen nimmt zu
in den rot gestreiften autos sitzen
fahrschüler aus um ihn
sie versuchen die engen kurven zu
bewältigen was nicht immer gelingt
hinter der nächsten kurve kommt ein
unfall
was mich nicht weiter erstaunt passiert
ist dies auf ein wenig brief schaden
nichts
es ist nicht so schlimm der gebürtige
niederländer der in kunming lebt kennt
die probleme der fahrschüler
diese straße ist bekannt für seine
vielen fahrschülern bei der alte bot
kaum mehr benutzt wird lernt man hier
fahren diese gelben schilder haben nur
fahrschulen das letzte zeichen bedeutet
schule lernen die meisten in lünern
realisieren gar nicht dass sie
tatsächlich auf der altenburger roth
autofahren lernen einfach weil sie leer
ist
es ist genau das problem in china man
lernt auf solchen straßen und straßen
ja und wenn ein großer lastwagen kommt
geht schief
diese junge frau hat den unfall
verursacht irgendwie auch in der stadt
[Musik]
ja aber nicht oft weil wir immer noch
lernen
in der stadt gibt das dichten verkehr
und man befürchtet dass er mit so
schwierigen straßenverhältnissen nicht
umgehen kann
aber wenn wir hier draußen genügend
geübt haben können wir auch innerhalb
der stadt fahren
auf der weiterfahrt geht mir die
beunruhigende unfallstatistik chinas
nicht aus dem kopf unsere heutige etappe
führt mich von kunden hin zur ehemaligen
königsstadt dar
die ort burma roth führt durch gegen die
noch sehr ursprünglich sind neutral
chinas der vom wirtschaftsboom noch
nicht erfasst worden ist
[Musik]
wir übernachten in ankara
was übersetzt südliche blume heißt eine
typische chinesische kleinstadt neue
monster begleitet uns einen weiteren tag
eher will die legenden die sich um die
oldtimer dran kommt für uns aufleben
lassen
die kälte setzt mehr zu doch er packt
tatkräftig an er hat bereits eine heiße
suppe machen
[Musik]
hier fuhren während des kriegs schwer
beladene lastwagen entlang die
alliierten unterstützten chinesische
soldaten im kampf gegen die japaner und
versorgten sie mit lebensmitteln und
waffen aus burma heute gehört sie zu den
größten handels- und schmuggelrouten
asiens die menschen hier leben vor allem
von tabak reis und eukalyptus zu jeder
anständigen der reise serie gehört eine
autopanne hier ist sie der motor steigt
wir stecken fest
zum glück ist herr lee krisenerprobt und
legt sich mit den kollegen ins zeug und
ich weiß chinesen synnex beim
improvisieren da stimmt mich
zuversichtlich neue monster premiere in
der zwischenzeit zeigen wie chinas
gigantischer hunger nach rohstoffen den
kleinen nachbarn myanmar aus sagt
weiblein führte von indien bis nach
kunming
sie sollte die treibstoffversorgung für
die kampfflugzeuge gegen die japaner
sicher stehen im zweiten weltkrieg wurde
es dann bauten sie zwei neue pipelines
von burma marina der eine vollgas und
eine für höhen kann man sie gut sehen
entlang der hügel diese kahlen stellen
[Musik]
kommt dieser alten verbindungsstraße für
china wieder eine große strategische
bedeutung zu ja auch für jena
wir suchen direkte versorgung mit gas
und öl haben gibt es all diese fabriken
mit den hohen kaminen
sie ist die moll ihren auch die
wirtschaft juni selbst harry ist
machtlos gegenüber den tücken der
technik das auto muss in die garage wir
steigen
die fahrt geht weiter
der früher als katastrophe logistiker
arbeitete erzählt mir mehr über die
oldtimer raus sie ist seine große
leidenschaft
so sagt er verhinderte dass die schwer
beladenen lastwagen in schlamm versanken
dann steigt louis adrenalinspiegel hier
als die flieger basis der legendären
flying tigers
von hier aus bogen amerikanische piloten
im zweiten weltkrieg war sie die
attacken gegen die japanischen angreifer
wir sind hier auf dem höchsten punkt der
tempel hinter uns war die funkstation
mit dem frühwarnsystem der flying tigers
der luftstützpunkt war hier sieht nicht
viel
dieses dorf dort ist juni gewährt das
clan entlang der autobahn führte die
startpiste und man kann sich gut
vorstellen wie die flieger abheben
ja ich habe auf einem ipad einen alten
propagandafilmen wir können das
anschauen
das ist auch hörenswert der start ist
nur noch eine frage von sekunden
[Musik]
diese mutigen zehn piloten vertrieben
die japaner aus chongqing der weltweit
am heftigsten bombardierten statt
es ist amerikas erste derartige hilfe
für china danke onkel ein teil des
erfolgs amerika wollte das der grund war
toll habe nach dem angriff der japaner
aber amerika gelähmt die einzigen die
etwas gegen die japaner ausrichten
konnten waren die flying tigers
amerika braucht dringend gute
neuigkeiten
sie kamen einzig von den flying tigers
diese freiwilligen die weit weg in china
den japanern erbittert widerstand
leisteten
in die nacht hinein waren wir nach
die stadt sei wie ein eigenes universum
in china habe ich gehört
[Musik]
ich musste mich nein im gasthaus zur
burg
zur begrüßung kriege ich einen
aromatischen hojati zubereitet von gashi
der tag beginnt mit einem wohligen
gefühl der entspannung
da liest sehr tolerant
hier ist marina viel freier als in
anderen städten ja freiheit und eine
bessere lebensqualität
der größte unterschied ist das wetter es
ist ganz anders als in peking in dali
ist der himmel jeden tag blau
die luft ist frisch und kann frisches
gemüse kaufen
frische blumen jeden tag
gute luft besonders essen da kommt mir
vor wie eine insel mitten in china ein
ort der kreativen und freigeister
[Musik]
meine gastgeber ski & young kaufen auf
dem markt die zutaten für das
mittagessen ein
die beiden sind so genannte orphan
refugees stadt flüchtlinge aus peking
sie hatten genug von der
umweltverschmutzung und den
lebensmittelskandalen chinas wirtschaft
entwickelt sich seit 10 20 jahren rasant
es geht auf kosten der umwelt
luftverschmutzung wasserverschmutzung
und kontaminierte erde sind ja auswirken
all das zeigt sich auch in der nahrung
durch inas reformen und die öffnung ist
viel erreicht worden aber es sind auch
viele werte verloren gegangen
es gibt menschen die sich nur noch über
geld und macht definieren sie wollen
immer reicher werden ohne über die
folgen nachzudenken
für maximalen profit gefährden sie die
gesundheit anderer menschen mit dem
umzug in die ehemalige königsstadt dalí
haben sich ski & young für einen
schlechtes leben entschieden
für ihr in peking war das anders da was
haben sie eine volle agenda beide
arbeiteten aus engagierte journalisten
jetzt macht die 26-jährige betten in
ihrem gasthaus statt wirtschafts
beiträge für staatliche fernsehen
es fiel schon nicht leicht ihren
einstigen traum job aufzugeben
als meine ideellen wertvorstellungen und
die realität immer mehr auseinander
klafften entschied ich mich für meine
überzeugung
mein traum vom journalismus war
zerbrochen aber ich wollte wenigstens
einen lebenstraum verwirklichen
darum finden wir mit diesem gasthaus
januar publizierten artikel über einen
chefbeamten der betrunken fuhr eine
menschen tötete und nicht bestraft wurde
er kam auf die schwarze liste nirgends
sind so viele journalisten inhaftiert
wie in china
ich musste mich ganz genau an strenge
vorgaben meiner vorgesetzten halten
diese unterschieden sich häufig von
meiner persönlichen meinung wenn unsere
betrachtungsweisen zu sehr auseinander
klafften führte das zu großen
meinungsverschiedenheiten zwischen mir
und den vorgesetzten
wir stoßen an auf die pressefreiheit und
auf das neue jahr liegt bei 10 56
prozentigen weiß nicht ob's stark sehr
stark
dann will ich den mann besuchen der die
kleinstadt dalí mit new york vergleicht
ein künstler der in seinem eigenen
museum wohnt hallo ich heiße partie
schön sie kennenzulernen hallo bitte
treten sie ein
es ist ein unglaublicher ort mit diesen
weg schwer zu glauben dass hans janin 76
ist seit vielen jahren pendelt er
zwischen dalí und new york das sind
meine werke das meiste malte ich in new
york ich ging nach new york um 1967 das
damals 68 es ist sehr minimalistisch
sind
an der warmen entdecke ich originale von
warhol und lichtenstein ist das ja die
sind so aus dem frühen 17
haben sie einen hund und roy
lichtenstein gut gekannt ja dass ich ab
und zu
[Musik]
der park in new york gab es damals pop
art minimalismus und zusammen
konzeptuelle richtungen liebe die frühen
70er und diese freunde
das waren sehr aufregende zeiten seines
facebook heißt dieses werk passbilder
aus den 60ern dienten als vorlage
aber seine aktuellen arbeiten sind von
den alten meistern inspiriert sie
entstehen in zusammenarbeit mit einer
behinderten tochter eva s 34 jährig als
klassischen vorlagen gestaltet sie etwas
ganz eigenes
haben wiederum verarbeitet ihre werke zu
collagen und fügt sie in ein neues
ganzes
ja es war für diese komposition nehme
ich evas bilder und engagiere sie neu
beim tee lerne ich hamms dritte frau
kennen und sprechen über dalí über
inspirationsquellen und über das
politische system
ich staune wie frei haben hier arbeiten
kann
das haben sich die wirklich genau
dieselben freiheiten als künstler ja du
ja die habe ich der grund ist dass sich
das heutige china auch ein wenig
verändert hat aber während der sechziger
oder siebziger jahren hätte ich hier
nicht heute ist meine kunst nicht mehr
so hektisch so ist meine freiheit aus
künstler aber ich hoffe schon dass china
sich nun etwas mehr öffnet
[Musik]
auch im nachtleben erfahre ich mit
meiner mitarbeit wenn sie von young das
einzigartige toleranz
mt steht für ihr geld
es ist einer der wenigen offenen
treffpunkt für schwule in china bis 2001
war gleichgeschlechtlicher liebe absolut
tabu und wurde bestraft
trotz der schätzungsweise 40 millionen
homosexuellen in diesem land
dieser junge mann hatte sein kommen
innerhalb der familie
sie akzeptiert hält es aber geheim
familien spricht mit außenstehenden
nicht über probleme alle sorgen sich
sehr um den gesichtsverlust skandale
werden vermieden und man schweigt aber
nicht alle familien nicht so tolerant
wie deine einige schwule suchen sich
dann eine lesbische freundin
sie organisieren eine scheinheirat mit
guter trend zur hochzeit kommen dann
alle familie und freunde wieder andere
heiraten eine heterosexuelle frau und
haben sogar kinder mit ihr
viele halten den druck nicht aus ein
paar wählen den extremen weg und begehen
suizid andere brechen aus und verlassen
ihre familie wieder andere geben auf und
heiraten unter druck der familie
jeder geht anders damit um
[Musik]
okay okay
vielen dank fürs es war wirklich schön
[Musik]
der abschied von ski und jan fällt mir
schwer
dauergast feature bietet mir an mich mit
einem chip ein paar kilometer weiter
nach ski zu fahren
er benötige etwas frischen wind um die
nase sagt er
schnell spüre ich dass er benzin im blut
hat neben trinken und schlafen habe er
noch eine andere lieblingsbeschäftigung
ich mag rallye fahren
das ist sehr stark und sehr männlich
das mag ich am allerliebsten da ließ
goldküste vor allem russen investieren
hier in hotels dann wird in der macho
unvermittelt sagt er sei großer fan von
john denver gesteht er
[Musik]
es überrascht mich dass du countrymusik
max
[Musik]
das linden center in chips bei den
besuchern eröffnet sich hier ein längst
verloren geglaubtes china genau das war
die absicht von brian und chemie linden
das fahrzeug von denver hierher
renovierte das verfallene haus und
eröffnete ein hotel für ausländer wie es
das fast immer noch unmöglich
heute kommen amerikanische noble schulen
zwecks kulturaustausch hierher auch
diejenige von präsident obamas töchtern
mich beeindruckt das haus voller
antiquitäten und die architektur der bei
minderheit
das ist wohl eines der großartige
beispiele traditioneller architektur
sie macht sich die 300 tage sonnenschein
er in dali haben mittels dieser
reflektierenden wand zu nutzen
diese hält die morgensonne ab aber wenn
die sonne höher steigt wird die wärme
und das licht hier her reflektiert bis
zum sonnenuntergang rein stammt aus
einfachen verhältnissen er war
schauspieler journalist und
antiquitätenhändler in den 80er jahren
zog es ihn hier unser ziel war die
bewahrung so wollten wir auf chinas
zerstörung seiner kultur reagieren dass
aus politischen gründen heute aus
finanziellen ja geradezu habgierigen
genie und ich wollten aufzeigen wie man
etwas restaurieren kann ohne es zu
zerstören und neu aufzubauen und wir
wollten die geschichte leben einhaucht
100 lokale arbeiter restaurierten 14
monate lang so entstand eines der
exklusivsten boutique-hotels chinas
hallo gehst du nach hause
alle im dorf kennen den amerikaner der
perfekt chinesisch spricht er ist der
größte arbeitgeber hier und hilft mit
die abwanderung zu verringern
eine familie trägt ihren verstorbenen
zur letzten ruhe in die berge musik und
knallkörper sollen böse geister
vertragen
[Applaus]
wer sich diesen alten namen ich heiße
bada ich komme vom schweizer fernsehen
ja sie kommt vom schweizer fernsehen
erinnert sich an den chinesisch
japanischen krieg und den weltkrieg und
an die amerikanische flugstaffel klein
tigers die über skiflug sahen jeweils
die roten und grünen lichter der freien
trägers sie haben die gegend vor den
japanern gerettet und als junge stand
ich an der olma rot und schaute zu wie
man nachschub für die soldaten brachte
ryan gehöre zu den zehn
einflussreichsten ausländern chinas hört
man sein rezept heiße sanfte diplomatie
die regierung hat ihm dieses zweite haus
zugesprochen
er will es aus kochschule und spa nutzen
für einen auf sender sei das ein großer
vertrauensbeweis sagt brian
wir haben wir eine 5.000 jährige kultur
die von amerika ist gerade einmal 200
irgendwas halt ich hoffe dass man hier
mein beispiel war nimmt
ich komme als mann aus dem westen reden
will wirklich ein teil chinas sein
ich befolge strikt die gesetze mehr als
manche chinesen ihr lebe ich meinen
traum
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge werde ich in die
vergangenheit zurückversetzt
ich besuche eine familie der naschi
minderheit deren kultur bedroht ist
durch die magische welt der output reise
ich bis an die grenze zu myanmar dem
früheren birma
hier will ich mehr erfahren über den
milliardenschweren handel mit jahre
[Musik]
rot grün rot mit globetrotter und
fernsehfestival siebte bis achte
november im kursaal bern fernsehfestival
punkt ch